some may say
a feminist may say to you
rolo you're just insecure you're afraid
we as women
are starting to take your jobs away and
we're making a market more competitive
why are you so insecure and afraid of us
okay what i would say is that's an
emotional argument and i'm making a
rational argument it's the same thing
it's a conversation killer who hurt you
that kills the conversation right there
if i go and i make all of these very
cogent very rational valid arguments or
i show you the statistics and say these
are just the step these are the stats
these are the dots that i'm connecting
and if your response is who hurt you or
you must be very bitter what was her
name you know or mommy didn't love you
that's an emotional response so it's the
same thing it's like well you're just
you're just an insecure man because
you're bringing this up no i am giving
you objective reality and you have no
counter argument these women that you're
saying you're speaking to that approach
you and have these conversations that
are doing well in life successful are
they're literally saying what do i have
to do dumb it down you've used that play
stupid you've used that terminology a
few times what does that actually look
like what is they're not going to just
start being a deal no what does that
actually look like
we're going to find out is what we're
going to what we're going to do
right now if you look at marriage rates
they're at the lowest they have ever
been since the in the united states
anyways than than when they started
recording this it's like i believe it's
up to
6.1 per thousand right now i believe
that it's 6.1 but it's at the lowest
rate it would have been six point one
percent
six point one per one thousand i believe
of the population it is
what does that mean statistically
speaking it's the marriage rate in the
united states is lower than yeah but
what's six point one per one
i got it off of um uh there's a woman
marriage per one thousand unmarried
women
years older so can you pull this up
because i'm actually really curious on
what that means
uh i do know fewer people are getting
married one thing that's the lowest rate
absolutely i mean i got one chart here
that says marriage more than a century
of change
if you go back to 50s 90.2 percent of
folks were getting married today it's
31.1 percent
yes okay the u.s marriage rate the
number of women's marriages per 1 000
unmarried women
15 years and older is the lowest it's
been in over a century at 31.1 that is
roughly 31 marriages
per 1000 unmarried women
the marriage rate was the highest in
1920 at 92.3
since 1970 the marriage rate has
declined almost 60 percent why is that
happening i would say it's because we
have a different understanding of how
men and women should interact with each
other we have taken away anything that
men might provide to women because
they're strong and independent women
right that side of hypergamy where it's
the the three ps parental investment
protection and provisioning women can do
that themselves
and uh when we have a social order that
makes men like homer simpson or we turn
them into incompetent men or we say we
can just simply look at the stats like
40 of guys are going to college right
now um there's this new uh i forget what
the uh
the guy's name john berger i think was
he coined this phrase called the golden
penis syndrome right it's like these
guys who are on top of their game
they're the god they're the alpha the
quote-unquote alpha males that all women
want to get with well they
don't need a man to provide security for
themselves anymore and they don't trust
a man to provide that security in the
first place because their whole concept
of masculinity is ridiculous or it's
abusive those are really the two or
incompetent those are the three
choices that we have so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]